nichts geht mehr Straßen vollgesperrt
Flüge gestrichen Züge fallen aus räum
und Streufahrzeuge im Dauereinsatz der
Winter hat die südliche Hälfte
Deutschlands so fest im Griff wie lange
nicht mehr das kam so plötzlich Eis da
er da so gut wie gar nichts gemarkt die
Autobahn A6 bei St Ingbert es ist
spiegelglatt mehrere Autos verunfallen
und selbst die Einsatzkräfte kommen
nicht voran die Fahrbahn ist im Moment
nicht aber weder durch bergungsfahrzeuge
der Abschleppdienste noch durch andere
Fahrzeuge wir haben hier eine
geschlossene Eisdecke von ca einem
halben bis Zentimeter also im Moment ist
hier gefahrlos kein Verkehr möglich
ebenfalls unmöglich eine Bergung der
Fahrzeuge die Autobahn wird vollgesperrt
ein Streufahrzeug muss die Fahrbahn vom
Eis befreien verletzt wird niemand kurz
vor mir ist an der Unfall passiert und
mein LKW ist da noch ein bisschen nach
rechts weggerutscht wo ich die rett
habe gemacht habe und ich bin froh dass
die Polizei hier alles gesperrt hat
damit da nicht noch mehr passiert hier
ist mehr passiert die A8 bei Weilheim
Tech beim Überholen eines LKWs verliert
ein Autofahrer die Kontrolle über sein
Fahrzeug kollidiert mit der Leitblanke
und mit einem LKW ein Ersthelfer wird
von einem weiteren Auto erfasst und
schwer verletzt das klatteis sorgt zwar
in ganz BadenWürttemberg für zahlreiche
Unfälle meistens bleibt es allerdings
bei Blechschäden auch weil der
Winterdienst gut vorbereitet ist hier
sieht man die Eisfläche ganz gut dur
durch den gefrierenden Regen auf dem
gefrorenen Boden entsteht aber wenn man
in der Summe schaut hier Berufsverkehr
in Stuttgart die Straßenmeistereien
haben ganz gut vorgesorgt die Straßen
sind mit viel Salz abgestreut und es
gibt momentan keine herausragenden
Ereignisse in Baden-Württemberg sagt das
Lagezentrum und der Berufsverkehr in
Stuttgart fließt auch auch in normaler
Form wer allerdings mit dem Zug
unterwegs ist braucht mehr Geduld
wetterbedingt verspäten sich am
Stuttgarter Hauptbahnhof immer wieder
Züge oder fallen aus wir haben genug
Zeit wir werdet ankommen aber es ist
einfach nervig ja und mittlerweile
rechnet man ja schon gar nicht damit
dass es funktioniert der Deutsche
Wetterdienst waren für Mittwoch vor
einer ausgewachsenen unwetterlage mit
Blitzeis Eisregen und starken
Schneefällen in Teilen des Saarlandes
von rinenpfalz und Hessen sogar die
höchste Warnstufe am Frankfurter
Flughafen startet der Betrieb daher
zunächst stark eingeschränkt mehr als
die Hälfte der Flüge fallen aus die
lufthanser bittet ihre Passagiere um
Verständnis bei dem Wetter kann man
einfach nicht gut fliegen da geht
Sicherheit vor und deshalb müssen wir
dann einfach den Flugplan reduzieren wir
versuchen den Passagieren so gut es geht
zu helfen neue Flüge anzubieten
umzubuchen digitale Services
hochzufahren damit eben jedem schnellst
möglich geholfen werden kann wir können
jetzt nichts ändern ich muss nach
Schweden also insofern Daumen drücken
dass mich da nicht das Gleiche erwartet
es war ein bisschen frustrierend ich bin
gerade in Frankfurt gelandet dann wurde
mein Flug nach Hause gestrichen die Lage
ist wohl einfach unvorhersehbar
ungewiss auch wann es für sie weitergeht
die A64 vor der Grenze zu Luxemburg
hunderte LKWs reihen sich hier
eineinander wegen extremer Klette gilt
für sie ein Fahrverbot doch warum ist
die Wetterlage gerade jetzt so prisant
von Südwesten ist sehr milde Luft mit
Regen herangezogen dieser regenfällt auf
den gefrorenen Boden und bilden sich
Eispanzer nicht nur auf dem Boden
sondern auch an Gegenständen an
Strommasten an Gerüsten an Kränen und an
Bäumen es droht also Eis und Schneebruch
dieser Streifen mit dem gefährlichen
Glatteisregen erstreckt sich vom
Saarland über reheinlandpfalz das
südliche Hessen bis nach Bayern nördlich
davon fällt viel Schnee 20 30 vielleicht
sogar 40 cm Schnee in einem Streifen von
der Eifel über das nordhässische
Bergland bis ins südliche SachsenAnhalt
nach Thüringen und Sachsen es bleibt
gefährlich auch hier in Teilen Bayerns
ist die Lage mancher Orts dramatisch wer
kann bleibt zu Hause oder stützt sich ab
auf der A96 bei buchloohe kracht ein LKW
in die mittelleitblanke wer mit dem Auto
auf dem Weg zur Arbeit ist muss sehr
viel Zeit einplanen auf die Nebenstraßen
war richtig froren lechalbrücke sehr
glatt habe ich mir schon dacht dass ich
wieder umdrehe wir sind heute extra
früher aufgestanden ich hatte heute in
der Früh schon das Problem dass mein
Auto eingefroren ist ich musste mit M
Wasser das Auto frei machen
es ist sehr glatt auf die Nebenstraßen
es ist auch stoppender Verkehr ich bin
mit 60 km Heer Gefahren schneller ging
auch nicht was in München aber scheinbar
immer geht Surfen im Eisbach auch bei
Temperaturen weit unter dem
Gefrierpunkt es ist wie Skifahren für
mich die Leute fragen mich ist dir nicht
kalt ja klar ist mir kalt aber wenn man
die richtigen Klamotten anhat ist alles
gut schöne Aktivität gerade im Winter wo
es eigentlich viel zu kalt ist irgendwie
draußen Sport zu machen der Dicke Anzug
hält schön warm wie ihr seht ich dampfe
kein keine weit und breit keine Kälte
empfinden gerade Kälte Schnee und Eis
bekommt der südliche Teil Deutschlands
noch länger zu spüren der Winter behält
ihn weiterhin fest im
Griff